what food group is going to be impacted
the most is it me going to the grocery
store or is it me going to a restaurant
well there's always impact versus
perception so all the stocks might not
trade the right way but that being said
for you and i as consumers it's really
going to be at the grocery store and
it's really going to be with eggs not
chicken
why is that why aren't the chickens and
chicken breasts and chicken thighs being
affected the way that eggs are
well right now it looks like the flu
has been in the egg laying hens and like
you had said it's 2x if not more the
last outbreak we could really measure
here
in the
1983-84 period and it's really not at
all within the broiler hens and the
broilers or the broiley chickens that's
what goes through the food supply chain
how long does something like this last
you know going back to that outbreak in
the 80s
prices increased almost 150 percent for
those liquid eggs that are used as input
for consumer products and it took a long
time for those prices to regulate
it really did it took as much as 24
months to get to some kind of
equilibrium of course the initial spike
didn't last that entire period but it
did take quite a while to get back to a
steady state
so nicole let's talk about what
companies are affected directly here
what would you say what stands to lose
out
well from us from a from a restaurant
company perspective
it would be anybody that over indexes
two eggs which could be those that over
index to the breakfast day part it could
be a mcdonald's it could be a sonic but
even that is very immaterial when you
consider
if it were to get into the chicken
population which again we don't which is
a pre protein that's much more
substantial for the restaurant operators
you know in your recent note nicole you
sort of made the distinction between
companies that are franchisees operate
operated and those that are not why is
this relevant when you're dealing with a
potential supply crunch
it's really critical to point out that
for investors if you are concerned about
this to stick with the highly franchised
models albeit it could definitely impact
their franchisees in the short term it
would have zero literally zero impact
potentially on a consolidated p l as
some of these brands like a qsr like a
duncan are 99 franchised operators do
you see any of this priced into these
companies shares nicole
actually you know we have seen some
volatility i look at as a fiesta for
example and looking back over the past
quarter or so there were concerns with
oil in texas and they over index there
there's concerns again
very topical concerns by investors about
chicken because again this is not in the
broiler populate population but that's a
stock that it continually see selling
off
and in your in your recent you also
mentioned chipotle being potentially at
risk they're planning to open 205 new
stores this year does something like
this have a significant impact on their
potential to grow
well we did point out that if it were to
happen and we think the probability is
very very unlikely it is a company-owned
model number one and it is above the
fifteen percent um threshold in terms of
chicken as the in in terms of the cost
of goods sold basket that being said
this is something that would be
short term in nature and would have no
impact on their balance sheet which
would you know have no impact therefore
on their new unit development